in today's eight on your side
a modern approach to online estate
planning released a study of 20 000
millennials
their thoughts on estate planning and
end of life and they found that the
general uncertainty that came about
during the pandemic plus the election
and the fight for social justice
led 76 percent of millennials to create
trusts or whales last year
patrick hicks is the head of legal at
trust and will he says millennials are
now
25 to 40. they're reaching a point where
they're having families buying homes
estate planning can be a daunting task
no matter what age you are but he says
trust and will wants to make the process
simple
we like to think of ourselves something
like turbo tax for estate planning it's
something that
it uses technology but it's an
approachable and easy way for you to put
your plan together
we've made it so it's a step-by-step
process so trust and well may be a great
option for you to create a plan
but maybe what you can just start by is
thinking about what's important to you
and if
something were to happen what would you
want to happen to your kids and your
pets and your family and just starting
to think through that process
typically leads you towards the
direction of ultimately deciding now is
the time to put a plan in place
trusted will offers digitally signed
electronic wills in our state you can
get the process started at
trustanwale.com
christian